[Musik]
willkommen bei Bild ihr ganzes Leben
steckt voller Debatten voller Streit
voller Diskussion die sie führt mit
ganzer Kraft mit Freude auch an der
Provokation und jetzt streitet sie gegen
den aktuellen Regierungskurs im
ukrainekrieg gegen immer neue
Waffenlieferungen und dafür will sie
morgen 10.000 Menschen auf die Straße
bringen zu einer zu ihrer
Großdemonstration die richtigen Fragen
jetzt hier bei Bild an Alice Schwarzer
Herzen erwiesen wir alle haben nicht die
Lösung für diesen Krieg parat wir alle
zweifeln auch viele von uns an der
eigenen Meinung auch oft in diesem Krieg
zweifeln auch Sie in diesem Tagen an
auch ihrer Position manchmal das nicht
aber ich suche das Gespräch also z.B die
aktuell immer titelt mit dem Satz wir
müssen reden das ist ganz klar ich
unterstelle mal denen die andere
politische Einschätzung sind als ich
nicht dass sie böse meinen sondern dass
sie einfach denken der andere Weg ist
der bessere aber Irrtümer gerade im
Krieg sind ja
Differenz vor allen Dingen natürlich von
denen die diesen Krieg führen aber auch
Sie werden sich mit diesen wichtigsten
Fragen im Moment jeden Tag
wahrscheinlich quälen diese
Zerrissenheit die im Moment Millionen
Deutsche führen spüren spüren Sie die
nie tatsächlich sind sie völlig sicher
nein aber doch gerade deswegen mische
ich mich ein weil ich eine hohe
mitleidungsfähigkeit habe das würde ich
mal sagen und immer auf der Seite der
Opfer bin und wir haben jetzt in diesem
Krieg
über ein Jahr gibt es schon über 200.000
tote laut Experten an der Front
550.000 Tote in der in der Heimat in der
Ukraine reden wir nicht von dem
vergewaltigten Frauen von den
traumatisierten Kindern und jeder Tag
kostet
hunderte von neuen Toten und darum muss
man sich nach der Verhältnismäßigkeit
Fragen und nach dem Ziel und die Antwort
auf diese beiden Fragen bisschen mehr
zur Zeit also es lässt sich ja bald das
Argumentieren wir geben den Ukrainern
immer mehr Waffen und die können Sie
immer mehr sich wehren und auf allen
Seiten wird gestorben oder wir
investieren wirklich in den Versuch zu
verhandeln und diesen Krieg zu Ende zu
bringen wir steigen gleich tiefer in
dieser Argumentation ein ich möchte noch
mal bei den Zweifeln und bei Irrtümern
bleiben was wenn Sie Ihren
wissen Sie
zur Zeit wird von den Männern und Frauen
an der Macht wird gepokert im Grunde mit
der ganzen Welt ja also ja
wenn wir jetzt die roten Linien bei
Putin überschreiten
wird er dann wirklich schlägt der
wirklich hart zurück und greift
vielleicht sogar nach Atomwaffen oder
tut er das nicht auch nicht ich glaube
das eigentlich nicht dass er das tut
also ich meine abends am Bier an der
Biertheke kann man so reden was meinst
du so und so jetzt müssen wir einfach
endlich
das geringste Risiko gehen ja also jedes
hohe Risiko schadet nicht nur Tag für
Tag der Menschen in der Ukraine sondern
bringt uns ein Weltkrieg Atomkrieg näher
jetzt wird es richtig ernst wir steigen
ganz tief ein gleich Frau Schwarz
trotzdem wegen dieser Zweifel noch mal
bei meiner Frage bleiben was passiert
meine Position sie wenn sie sich irren
wenn ich falsch erstens ist meine
Meinung leider nicht der bedeutend ich
sitze ja nicht in der Regierung aber sie
wollen morgen 10.000 mobilisieren
bringen im Moment ganz viele Menschen ja
auch das sagen sie auch immer hinter
sich ist das kein Schaden wissen sie
weil meine Position ist eine Position
die die Verhandlung sucht und den
Frieden ja wenn ich mich geirrt habe ich
weiß nicht was man sich da irren könnte
wenn man wenn die Militär ist alle sagen
es ist eine past Situation keiner kann
das militärisch gewinnen wir selbst die
sagen dass selbst der oberste Militär in
den USA in der generell wir müssen jetzt
verhandeln glaubst du dann kann das
keinen Schaden anrichten ich würde nur
Schaden anrichten deswegen schlafe ich
sehr ruhig und bin absolut empfehlen mit
meinem Engagement ich würde nur Schaden
anrichten wenn ich sagen würde noch mehr
Panzer noch mehr Waffen weil wissen sie
Panzer sind tötungsinstrumente ja und da
hätte ich dann doch eine unruhige Nacht
wenn ich an jedem Tag ein paar
hundertote auf dem Pelz hätte jede Waffe
richtet Schaden an und gleichzeitig ist
es so dass die Waffenlieferung natürlich
im Moment der Verteidigung der Ukraine
helfen das wissen sie genau das gilt für
den Beginn des Krieges da ist die
Ukraine brutal überfallen worden und da
haben wir Waffen geliefert damit sich
verteidigen kann und das ist gut so
jetzt haben wir ein Jahr Krieg
und wir sind weiter entfernt von
Verhandlungen denn je also beide Seiten
werden immer starr und immer
bedrohlicher wir denken total in
Schwarz-Weiß wir sehen nur noch Opfer
und Täter und so weiter
und wie gesagt selbst die Militär sagen
wir können den Krieg wir können den
Krieg nicht militärisch gewinnen sagen
sogar die amerikanischen Experten die ja
nun am Krieg sehr mitverantwortlich sind
und jetzt nach einem Jahr reden wir äh
wieso haben sie das Wort gehört vom
Verschleiß Verschleiß heißt das glaube
wie heißt das noch mal verschleißkrieg
oder von dem zu mögen denn ähm
ich glaube abnutzungskrieg
beispielsweise jetzt stell mal vor wir
reden über Menschen wir reden über
Menschen abnutzungskrieg also da kann
ich mich gar nicht hören wenn ich sage
so früh wie möglich jetzt Verhandlungen
weil man hat gesehen man kann es
militärisch nicht gewinnen sie richten
diesen Appell an den Westen an die
Bundesregierung an die NATO auch an die
Ukraine an dem Tag an dem keine Waffen
geliefert werden an dem Tag an dem der
Ukraine die Waffen an der Front ausgehen
was passiert an diesem Tag also ich
richte nicht ich bin ja nicht größer
wahnsinnig ich richte diesen Appell
nicht an die Nato und an die Ukraine ich
richte den an die politisch
Verantwortlichen die ich gewählt habe
also oder wir gewählt haben mehrheitlich
ich richte das an unsere Regierung
[Musik]
die sich bei ihnen gemeldet haben sie
diesen Konflikt ausgetragen haben sie
miteinander diskutiert hat der Kanzler
bei ihnen angerufen ich habe ja bereits
im April eine Initiative ergriffen den
offenen Brief an den Kanzler zunächst
habe ich verstanden hatte was anderes zu
tun als uns zu antworten aber als er
inzwischen bei einer halben Millionen
halben Millionen haben schon den offenen
Brief unterzeichnet und mit dem Manifest
jetzt erwartet dass er er hat da habe
ich erw eigentlich mal reagiert nun hat
er auf das Manifest das innerhalb von
zwei Wochen von über 600.000 Menschen
unterzeichnet wird ja und ich weiß nicht
wie viele morgen kommen es hat es glaube
ich in Deutschland noch einige sind
wieder abgesprungen andere kamen dazu
finden Sie das wie werden ja klar
äußert und hat irgendwie gesagt also er
hat gar kein Verständnis für das man
fest genau
sagen ich bin sehr überrascht
dass wir ein Kranzer haben der ein
Manifest das innerhalb von zwei Wochen
von über 600.000 Menschen unterzeichnet
worden ist und von denen die Mehrheit
der Bevölkerung ist glaube ich aus Ihrem
Hause die Umfrage oder ja auch immer die
Mehrheit der Bevölkerung gesagt
aktueller laut aktueller Umfrage wir
finden das Manifest gut du lieber Gott
also da habe ich eigentlich erwartet
dass ein
SPD-Kanzler von dem ich bisher den
Eindruck hatte dass er eher auf unserer
Seite steht das auch sein Bestreben oder
seine Hoffnung ist das bald verhandelt
wird den Eindruck hatte ich bisher
dass der die Mehrheit des Volkes nicht
ernst nimmt dass der eine solche
Initiative die so explodiert und darum
sind wir jetzt auch eine halbe Stunde
hier die die Menschen so
ins Nachdenken bringt egal welchen
Schlüssel sie ziehen dass er die nicht
ernst nimmt also da bin ich doch bin ich
erstaunt erstaunt enttäuscht enttäuscht
ja enttäuscht warum glauben Sie warum
ich enttäuscht bin nee warum er sich
nicht bei Ihnen meldet was glauben Sie
das nicht bei uns melden das ist also
steck ich locker weg das ist nicht das
ist sehr enttäuscht sagen Sie also ja
mir geht es gar nicht mehr darum ob er
sich bei uns meldet sondern mir geht es
darum dass er eine solche das fängt ja
wirklich an eine an einer Bürgerbewegung
zu werden ja der Protest gegen nur
Waffen liefern und gar nicht öffentlich
auf Verhandlung denken dass er seine
Bürger gar nicht ernst nimmt ich hatte
eigentlich erwartet gerade vollständig
im Prinzip durchaus schätze dass der
sagt ja
dass der sich sozusagen bestärkt fühlt
durch unsere Initiative weil er wird ja
als Zögerer beschimpft was ich was ich
persönlich und offensichtlich Millionen
Menschen in diesem Land sehr gut fand
man muss nicht rasch in den Krieg
marschieren das ist etwas ganz ernstes
da darf man und muss man sehr genau
darüber nachdenken und Deutschland hat
ja nach Amerika eine zentrale Funktion
in diesem Konflikt also das ist schon
mit entscheidend was wir tun sie sagten
gerade einander ernst nehmen ernsthaft
über unterschiedliche Meinung
diskutieren das wollen wir tun und wir
wollen eben vor allen Dingen bei dieser
Frage bleiben was passiert an dem Tag an
dem es keine Waffenlieferung mehr gibt
an dem Tag an dem die Waffen ausgehen an
dieser heißen sie mich vielleicht naiv
also ich habe jetzt nicht jeden wir
haben in unserem Manifest nicht jeden
Schritt ausgearbeitet das muss natürlich
Hand in Hand gehen man fängt an drüber
zu reden und
es gibt eine gegenseitige Bereitschaft
Behandlung und dann muss es ein
Waffenstillstand geben und erst dann
wenn die Russen anfangen sich aus den am
Februar vergangenen Jahres besetzen
Gebieten zurückzuziehen erst dann kann
man sagen und ist ein wirklich echten
Waffenstillstand gibt erst dann sagt man
man liefert keine Waffen mehr ist ja
klar aber nur dieses Waffen liefern ohne
jeden diplomatischen Versuch das heißt
einmal richtig verstehen sie sagen jetzt
Voraussetzungen für den Stoff von
Waffenlieferung muss schon sein dass die
sich zurückziehen habe ich sie da
richtig verstanden
will stillstand gibt ja und da und im
Anschluss an den wirklich
eingelösten ernsthaften Waffenstillstand
gibt es die Verhandlungen und dann
müssen beide Seiten Kompromisse machen
ich habe ein bisschen anders verstanden
auch hier im Manifest war schwarze das
heißt damit sagen sie solange Waffen
liefern ist okay
solange die russennische Armee sich
keinen Zentimeter bewegt und weiter nach
vorne bewegt
also
selensky hat im vergangenen Herbst ein
Dekret erlassen Dekret hier kommt der
Befehl des Präsidenten das nicht
verhandelt werden darf also das heißt
wir spielen gegen wir kämpfen gegen
diese größte atomacht der Welt zu lang
bis hier kein Mann und keine Maus mehr
ist und das ganze Land zerstört ist
Russland hatten meine Auffassung nach
gerade indirekt mit der chinesischen
Initiative die wird ja mit Russland
abgesprochen sein winziger Hoffnung
Schimmer in diesen Tagen gleichzeitig
fehlt ein noch die Fantasie tatsächlich
dran zu glauben dass das seine
Entscheidung sein könnte wir müssen
daran glauben erstens wie lange wollen
Sie denn noch die Menschen da sterben
lassen auf diesem Schlachtfeld Ukraine
die sind ja als erste dran das ist halt
furchtbare Vorstellung möchte niemanden
sterben lassen sie dann müssen sie für
Verhandlung bedienen müssen sich eine
weiße Frieden alle plädieren für
Verhandlungen nur wir sehen auch
gleichzeitig wir können uns ganz kurz
nochmal die aktuelle Karte überhaupt
nicht aktuell alle für Verhandlung wir
können jetzt Ministerin wenn ich das
sagen darf die die erste Diplomatin ist
ja spricht von Krieg mit Russland und
spricht nur von Waffenlieferungen ich
hoffe dass sie vielleicht geheim ohne
dass wir das wissen ihre förderste
Aufgabe
Aufgabe wahrnimmt zu Verhandlung
beizutragen die Äußerung die sie auf die
sie anspielen hat sie später erklärt
müssen wir der Verhältnis selber hier
auch sagen die führen sie ja auch in
ihrem Manifest noch mal auf diese
unglückliche Äußerung der
Außenministerin die auch intern in der
Regierung für Ärger gesorgt hat mit dem
Kanzler wir schauen uns die aktuelle
Karte noch mal von der Ukraine an hier
hinter uns Frau Schwarzer da sehen sie
den aktuellen Frontverlauf sie sehen in
rot die aktuell russisch besetzen
Gebiete die nach dem 24 Februar
vergangenen Jahres eingenommen wurden
und wir sehen in blau die Gebiete die
sich die Kabine seitdem auch wieder
zurückgeholt hat nochmal die Frage weil
sie so entscheidend ist was würde
passieren wenn wir jetzt sagen wir sind
völlig überzeugt von unserem
friedensmanifest von unserem
Friedensgedanken und liefern jetzt keine
Waffen mehr was würde dann ich habe ihn
eben schon darauf geantwortet also ein
Manifest von 30 Zeilen ist kein dickes
paper wo wir jetzt die Strategie genau
ausarbeiten
wir wollen das endlich die Diplomatie
auch gleichzeitig eine Rolle spielt und
das wird zu dem Punkt kommen wo es von
beiden Seiten vernünftigerweise wäre das
noch sitzen wir hierher Drucken im
Studio die sind ja die ersten Opfer ja
dass man dahin kommt dass man sagt ja
Verhandlungen sind wünschenswert und um
die Verhandlung zu beginnen brauchen wir
einen Waffenstillstand so es wird
erstmal nicht mehr geschossen
und dann muss einfach klar werden vom
Besten her auch das auch er das will ja
weil ich finde das so erstaunlich können
sich jetzt spricht man sogar von einem
Stellungskrieg wissen Sie wann ich zum
letzten Mal das Wort gehört habe in den
50er Jahren von meinem Großvater der war
in Werner und der hat mir erzählt dass
am 24 Dezember die Soldaten auf beiden
Seiten aus dem Gräben kamen sich in den
Arm genommen haben geweint haben und ab
dem 25 Dezember haben sich wieder
erschlagen erwirkt und erschossen ich
meine ich habe doch nicht gedacht dass
ich in meinem Leben wieder mit einer
solchen Barbara wie einstellungskrieg zu
tun das haben wir alle nicht gedacht das
haben wir vor allen Dingen alle
überhaupt nicht gewollt es gab eine ein
Angriff in der Aggression am 24 Februar
vergangenen Jahres wir sehen in diesen
Tagen den russischen Machthaber Vladimir
Putin bei Feierlichkeiten in Moskau und
sehen ihn unter anderem so sprechen
auch im Moskauer Stadion vor 10.000
jubelnden Menschen vor Soldaten vor
Kindern noch einmal das für die
Eskalation ausschließlich der Westen
verantwortlich sei was empfinden Sie bei
diesen Auftritten einmal den Kopf
ausschalten was empfinden Sie bei denen
sagen ich sehe ein Beweis dafür dass
beim Krieg immer die einen sagen wir
sind die guten und die anderen sind die
Bösen und die anderen sagen wir sind
aber die guten die anderen es gibt aber
was soll an ihm gut sein also wenn Sie
wenn Sie sagen hier ist nicht gut und
böse klar verteilt seine Auffassung
seine Auffassung
und ich würde auch sagen
es geht hier nicht um Moral es geht hier
nicht darum wie man Herr putet oder eine
selensky oder an beiden findet ja es
geht um Machtverhältnisse und es geht
darum Menschen
immer gesagt unschuldige Menschen aber
ich finde entschuldige davon auch nicht
einfach umbringen also Menschen zu
schützen dass man sie in den Krieg wirft
ins Wasser wird dann aber schauen Sie
ich wollte einmal rausfinden weil wir
alle haben Gefühl auch zu diesen Bildern
das macht was mit uns wenn es diese
Auftritte gibt dort vor seinen Militärs
dann später auch im Fußballstadion mir
läuft er ehrlich gesagt ein kalter
Schauder über den Rücken was empfinden
Sie dabei
ich nehme das ernst und ich finde das
sehr bedrohlich und ich meine dass wir
uns mit der größten Atommacht der Welt
an einen Tisch setzen sollten und reden
und ich weiterballern weil irgendwann
kommt dann die finale Waffe und sie
wissen was das ist und da sitzen wir
auch hier in Deutschland und in Europa
nicht mehr im Trocknen wenn Sie mit dem
verhandeln müssten dann sitzen sie an
einem sehr langen Tisch wie wir wissen
an den kleinen Sätze also ich muss in
der Zeit mit dem Chinesen und dann sagt
er ihnen verantwortlich für die
Eskalation sind alleine sie ist alleine
der Westen
sie aber das haben die anderen auch ich
würde ihm antworten wissen sie lassen ja
mal die Vorgeschichte die kompliziert
ist seit 9 Jahren gibt es ja da ein Hin
und Her in der Ukraine wo im Grunde die
beiden Weltmächte zusammenprallen ich
würde sagen das interessiert uns jetzt
nicht lieber herr Präsident wir wollen
dass das Sterben aufhört und jetzt sagen
Sie mal ihrem Preis und dann nicht
meinen Preis und sie wissen ja das ist
auch auf dem Markt so auf dem arabischen
Markt doch ein bisschen stärker als bei
uns dann fängt man an zu verhandeln zu
gucken wo kann ich Konzessionen machen
mein einziges Bestreben ist für die
Menschen dass dieser Krieg so bald wie
möglich aufhört wir führen ihn wir alle
weil wir wissen führt ja durch seine
Waffenlieferung diesen Krieg mit wir
führen ihn seit einem Jahr
das positive Resultat ist dass die
Ukraine sich dank der Unterstützung des
Westens zur Wehr setzen konnte nicht
also das war ja ein brutaler Überfall
auf das Land und deswegen finde ich es
richtig dass wir zunächst Waffen
geliefert haben das ist das Positive ja
und der Adresse hat gesehen so einfach
ist das nicht ist kein Spaziergang wegen
der Krim und die Stimmung anders ist
sondern die sagen moment mal ja draußen
bleiben
das Negative ist dass es sich zieht und
zieht und zieht und immer mehr verhärtet
wer immer mehr in diesem Hass denken
drin sind ja also hier sind die Menschen
und da sind die Monster und so weiter
und immer aber uns ein bisschen
verrückten und gehen in dem Perspektive
dann sehen wir dass die das genau
umgekehrt sind lassen sie uns lassen Sie
einfach schauen wie wir aus diesem Krieg
rauskommen und wie wir und und hoffen
dass wir uns nicht immer mehr einem
atomkriegt werden
es geht hier um die Existenz der Welt
also der UN-Generalsekretär guteras der
hat ja jüngst gesagt wir gehen nicht
schlafen dadurch in diesen Krieg ist
eine Anspielung auf auf einen wuchttitel
sondern wir gehen mit offenen Augen in
den weltkriegt das sagt der
UN-Generalsekretär ich bitte Sie was
soll man denn noch sagen
wenn ich ihr Manifest lese dass dass sie
gemeinsam ja auch mit
nicht initiiert haben dann verwundert
mich auf ihre Biografie eines sie haben
immer auf der Seite derer gestanden die
nicht die mächtigen waren sie haben
immer für die Selbstbestimmung gekämpft
nicht nur geworben wirklich gekämpft
fast bis zur Selbstaufgabe aber
gleichermaßen hat sie das wahnsinnig
bekannt gemacht aber immer auf der Seite
derer die für Selbstbestimmung gekämpft
haben in dieser Frage erscheint es mir
zum ersten Mal anders ich verstehe nicht
wieso
Selbstbestimmung mein Motiv ist sind die
Opfer ich denke an die Opfer sehr viele
junge das ist so ein großes Wort es gibt
viele Menschen auf der Welt und auch in
Deutschland den ich voll sehr also das
ist so ein ja sie verzeihen mir ein
psychologisches Geschwafel ich sehe da
einfach Gewaltverhältnisse und so wie
ich mich einsetze dass das Frauen und
Kinder nicht
Opfer sind von Gewalt in ihrer eine
Wohnung so setze ich mich dafür im
Weltmaßstab ein dass jetzt die Menschen
in der Ukraine nicht Opfer sind ich bin
ja ein paar mal gefragt worden der Frau
Schwarzer die Frauen werden doch
vergewaltigt wie kann das denn sein ich
meine was idiotisches habe ich noch nie
gehört in der Tat jeden Tag sterben
hunderte von Menschen und werden ich
weiß nicht wie viel Frauen vergewaltigt
und ich möchte das Schluss damit ist und
da mir die höchsten Militärs in der Welt
sagen dieser Krieg ist in einer
passsituation der ist nicht zu gewinnen
ja dann weiß ich nicht warum der noch
drei Jahre weitergehen soll das wissen
wir alle ja eben aber jetzt kommt ein
konstruktiver Vorschlag von uns die wir
diese Initiative ergriffen haben wir
müssen endlich stärker auf Verhandlungen
gehen
was steckt dahinter sie sagen dass den
Menschen unter anderem an der Frontlinie
dort wohnen nach wie vor Familien die
sind im Moment sehr froh dass
Waffenlieferung aus dem Westen kommen
und sie mit ihren Soldaten eine
Möglichkeit haben zu wehren die
russischen Soldaten zurückzudrängen und
ausgerechnet auch diesen Menschen sagen
was ist denn eigentlich hören Sie wo
bleibt unser Verstand was ist denn
dagegen zu sagen wenn man nach einem
Jahr Krieg in der partsituation sind und
alle hohen Militärs soweit sie nicht
ihre Karriere damit Gefährten sagen ganz
klar der Krieg ist militärisch nicht
gewinnen zu gewinnen ich finde es
absolut verantwortungslos denn Ukrainern
weiterhin zu suggerieren sie müssten auf
dem Schlachtfeld gewinnen die kleine
Ukraine die kann das nicht gegen die
fürchterlichen Dilemma in dem Moment wo
ich nicht mehr zurückgeschossen wird
wird einfach überrollt kommen die
russischen Soldaten aber doch eben sehr
klar gesagt dass das nicht meine
Auffassung ist meine Auffassung ist
neben diesen Krieg müssen
schnellstmöglich
diplomatische Bemühungen ähm muss man in
Gang setzen um zu diesem
waffensstillstand und zu Verhandlungen
zu kommen ich sehe aber in der
offiziellen Politik ich kann nur hoffen
dass er sich hinter verschlossenen Türen
anders darstellt sonst wäre es ja zum
verzweifeln ich sehe in der offiziellen
deutschen Politik ja fast nur kriegsätze
also wenn man hergeht und sagt der
andere ist ein Monster mit dem man
niemals verhandeln kann ich bitte Sie
verhandeln ja sogar mit den Taliban also
das monsterhafte ist steigerbar mit den
Taliban um Menschen zu schützen
rauszuholen natürlich verhandelt man
unabhängig von von der eigenen Sicht und
der Moral des Gegners wie gesagt das ist
eine Machtfrage verhandelt man gegen
gegen Tod und Gewalt es bleibt so dass
ich bei ihnen bei ihrem Manifest noch
nicht verstehe und sie sagen sie müssen
es gar nicht Schritt für Schritt
ausformulieren was der Schritt sein soll
und Putin zu überzeugen tatsächlich an
den Verhandlungstisch zu gehen sie haben
sich dafür gerade schon angesprochen mit
Sarah Wagenknecht zusammen sein
das Manifest verbindet sie beide gibt es
sonst etwas was sie beide verbindet was
haben sie gemeinsam also zunächst mal
wir haben uns vier wir sind uns vier
Tage vor Veröffentlichung des Manifestes
zum ersten Mal begegnet vorher haben wir
gemailt und gesoomt auch und
die Idee für das man ist fest
die ist ja erst Mitte Januar aufgekommen
da dachte ich es reicht es muss
irgendwas passieren und habe am 14
Januar Sarah Bank nicht geschrieben und
am 15 habe ich gesagt wollen wir an
Manifest machen am 15 hat sie
geantwortet ja was verbindet uns warum
habe ich ausgerechnet ihr geschrieben
weil mir sie hat mir im Frühling
geschrieben nach dem offenen Brief den
sie auch unterzeichnet hat und dann
haben wir sehr locker schon mal alle ein
zwei Monate kleine Informationen
ausgetauscht mir ist einfach aufgefallen
dass sie an erster Stelle in diesem Land
der Mensch ist der der Mut hat offen
auch als Pazifistin also für den Frieden
kämpfend aufzutreten niemand hat so klar
und unerschüttert diese Position bezogen
auch gegen die eigene Partei die
Position von Sahra Wagenknecht ist ja
bekanntermaßen auch sehr umstritten in
ihrer Partei und da dachte ich jemand so
mutiges und außerdem sozusagen am
anderen Ende der Wurst ja also hier ist
die
unabhängige Feministin die ihr Leben
lang außer parlamentarischen Protest
gemacht hat ich war ja noch nie Mitglied
einer Partei da ist das unbequeme
Mitglied der LINKEN die auch sehr viel
riskiert und das dachte ich das müsste
sich eigentlich dann müsste es eine sehr
Energie
diese Frau Sahra Wagenknecht ach das ist
für mich nicht das Wort für Menschen
wissen sie fasziniert weil ich zum
letzten Mal als Teenager von meinem
jeweiligen nein
sie hat meine Achtung das ist vielleicht
viel mehr als Faszination sie
Freundinnen geworden das kann man nicht
sagen aber wir haben wahnsinnig gut
zusammengearbeitet also was mir sehr
gefallen hat bisher bei Sarah
Wagenknecht ist dass sie ganz uneil ist
also zum Beispiel ich habe so ein
Entwurf für dass man die festgemacht
dann hat sie reagiert und ihrerseits
eine Menge reingebracht und so weiter
und das Licht zwischen uns völlig
komplikationslos fand ich sehr angenehm
weil es möglicherweise ihnen beiden auch
gleichermaßen nutzt zu dieser Zeit Frau
schwarze sie haben gerade Mut
angesprochen mit Blick auf Frau
Wagenknecht was kostet aber in diesen
Zeiten das was sie Mut nennen ist das
nicht gerade
die Fantasie was jemand wie wir der
sowas anzettelt was da los ist also also
ich kann Ihnen sagen
was kostet das denn kann ich Ihnen sagen
ein Tsunami
Impfungen aber öffentlichen vor allem in
den Medien in der Politik und so weiter
aber eben auch doch die Achtung und
Sympathie der Mehrheit der Bevölkerung
die sind ja immer so hingegangen
hinter mir zur Seite hinter uns nicht
hinter dem Kanzler das sollte ihm
zugegengegeben das haben sie im
vergangenen Jahr schon gesagt die
Umfragen sind etwa 50 müssen sagen sie
haben eine gewaltige Masse aber hinter
sich wie viele wird sich morgen zeigen
ich möchte bei dem Mut noch einmal
bleiben und sie sagen na mich kostet das
natürlich Mut weil ich eine gewaltige
Welle an Ablehnung gerade möglicherweise
Hassmails und vielleicht noch schlimmer
mich erreichen aber wäre es nicht viel
mutiger im Moment nach Russland zu
fahren auf dem Roten Platz
beispielsweise zu stehen dort im
Aggressor seine Meinung zu sagen sie
machen sich schlicht lächerlich also ich
meine
Putin hat gerade auf mich gewartet
wissen sie er kennt mich überhaupt nicht
aber was soll ich in Moskau also ist ja
ab und soll ich dann wünschen sie sich
dass ich mich dahin Stelle und sage
hallo du Aggressor du Macho was er ja
ist es weiß man ja die Lage in der
Frauen in in Russland oder der Lage der
Frauen überall ist nicht so vor mir gab
aber in Russland steigt gerade die
Gewalt hat man die Gesetze die Frauen
schützen zurückgenommen das gehört
nämlich zusammen wissen Sie die Schlacht
im Schlafzimmer und die Schlacht an der
Front also mein Ansprechpartner ist
meine Regierung und ich weiß dass
Deutschland eine sehr wesentliche Rolle
spielt im Guten wie im Bösen ich glaube
auch dass die Menschen die weiter auf
Krieg und Waffen
drängen das denn vielleicht gar nicht so
unrecht ist das Deutschland geschwächt
wird und ich muss ihn auch mal sagen
irgendwann muss ja selbst dieser Krieg
zu Ende sein
darf ich mal fragen was da mit dem
Waffen ist in welchem Zustand die Männer
sind sind immer viele dann ich wollte
noch überlegen was daran mutig ist
derzeit sie sagen okay sie haben ein
bisschen mehr Ärger an der Backe haben
möglicherweise den ein oder anderen
Freund verloren der vorher ganz
wahnsinnig gerne sich mit Alice
Schwarzer getroffen hat und im Moment
einfach wahnsinnig anderer Meinung ist
aber was kostet sie das an Mut während
jeden Tag ukrainische Soldaten dort an
der Front kämpfen und sich tatsächlich
während
eigenartige Logik wissen Sie also
erstmal habe ich selber noch nie gesagt
ich bin aber mutig gut die Menschen
schreiben mir das und sie haben von Mut
gerade gesprochen aber sie meinten ihr
Mann die fest dass sein mutig was ich
will nur rausfinden das ist ja nur eine
Frage Prozent der Medien so wie sie
anzutreten das verdammt mutig wissen sie
da lesen Sie komische Sachen
Entscheidung also ich meine ich habe
jetzt ein halbes Jahrhundert bin ich
eine engagierte Bürgerin und ja und habe
mich in einer Schlachten reingehauen
wenn alles richtig fand ich muss das
nicht es ist auch gern bei mir auf der
Wiese und streichelt meine Katze ja
wirklich ich glaube das glaube ich nicht
haben sie ich glaube das ist das ist
genau mögen in die Auseinandersetzung zu
sehen das war doch ihr Leben bisher ich
kann es nicht ertragen Unrecht zu sehen
und ich finde jetzt passiert der Ukraine
ein wahnsinniges Unrecht in der man ihr
diesen Unsinn einredet sie könnten
Russland definitiv besiegen und das Land
ruiniert und die Menschen tötet und uns
allen passiert Unrecht weil wir mit der
zunehmenden Gefahr eines Atomkrieges
konfrontiert sind wofür wofür warum
nicht jetzt verhandeln wenn man nach
einem zermürmungskrieg in drei Jahren
verhandelt also ganz ehrlich gesagt mir
fehlt mir fehlen jetzt zwei Dinge in
Deutschland bei den Meinungsmachern
die Bevölkerung ist anders was meinen
Sie wie viele viel Glück morgen und so
bin ich nur hier ein Kilometer durch
Berlin gehe und wie viel Strahlen das
Lächeln mich trifft aber mir fehlen zwei
Dinge mir fehlt zum einen die sachliche
Logik was ist wohin wollen wir was warum
das alles um zum Zweiten fehlt mir das
Mitgefühl wissen Sie wenn ich mich da
jetzt in diese Schlacht wenn ich so
sagen darf in diese papierende
schlachtwerfe dann habe ich einen
Stellungskrieg vor Augen und die
vergewaltigten Frauen und die die Kinder
in den Krankenhäusern die unsere
Außenministerin so gerne besucht und die
vielleicht manchmal nur wegen diese
Waffen im Krankenhaus sind die wir leben
sie Zuspruch aus der Ukraine bitte
kriegen sie Zuspruch aus der Ukraine die
Ukraine ist ein Land im Kriegszustand
und da gibt es zurzeit keine offenen
Meinung das ist so das ist immer so wenn
ein Land im Kriegszustand ist
ich höre von Journalisten die schwer
haben und
die Männer die nicht kämpfen wollen sind
der Dienst verpflichtet also
zwangsein gezogen zwischen 16 und 60 und
da heißt es 12.000 schon hätten versucht
über die Grenze zu kommen die kommen die
sind erst natürlich gesellschaftlich
geächtet und zweitens kommen die bedroht
den zehn Jahre Gefängnis also die
Ukraine ist jetzt ein Land im Schrecken
ja und
natürlich ist mir völlig klar dass es
weiterhin Menschen gibt und ich
bewundere das muss ich Ihnen wirklich
sagen die sagen nein wir wollen uns
maximal weiter mit Waffen verteidigen
und so weiter vielleicht würde ich das
auch tun wenn ich in der Ukraine sitze
aber ich kann mir den Luxus eines kühlen
Kopfes außerhalb angewöhnen und darf
deswegen weil sie mir gerade gesagt
haben wenn sie durch Berlin laufen
bekommen Sie in diesen Tagen viel
Zuspruch das glaube ich sofort wenn ich
auf die Umfragen schaue und dann schauen
was aber
passieren im Moment wenn sie in Kiew
über die Straße laufen würden und wäre
ihnen das wichtig dort Zuspruch zu
bekommen
natürlich also das Denken an den
Menschen in der Ukraine steht bei mir an
der Spitze sonst würde ich doch gar
nicht wissen Sie wie gesagt Garten und
Katze also ich habe ja auch schon ein
bisschen also man kann es ja immer gut
sein lassen aber
diese Zahlen und Stellungskrieg und das
ohne Ziel es wird ja zur Zeit von uns
her von Deutschland ich habe immer nur
von Deutschland nicht das Ziel dieses
Krieges klar definiert ja also das ist
ein rückender Gedanke und was die
Ukraine die UK und die Menschen denken
das ist auch eine Frage ihres
Informationsstandes und der Propaganda
die verbreitet wird die Propaganda ist
ja jetzt sehr stark der Präsident
präsentiert sich also sozusagen nur als
Soldat im Krieg und so weiter wissen sie
das ist keine gute Atmung sind das oft
gefragt worden und sie haben immer
wieder gesagt nein ich war nicht in der
Ukraine und ich plane auch nicht wir
haben uns einmal schon zum Gespräch
getroffen damals hier mit dem grünen
Toni Hofreiter damals haben sie das gar
nicht ausgeschlossen
dorthin zu fahren würden sie das tun
würden sie mit den Menschen endlich
zu anderen natürlich jederzeit würden
sie das mit Bild tun ja natürlich
jederzeit so ich würde aber herzlich
darum bitten im Gebiet auszuwählen oder
so wie bei der Besuch von beiden das
muss man auch mal sagen ist natürlich
Russland vorher informiert worden klar
und weil man kein Interesse an einem
solchen Maß von Eskalation hat wo er
sicher ist und dann hält sich dann
natürlich die Gegenseite weil sie auch
kein Interesse an Eskalation hat aber
dann wird dann trotzdem so ein
peinlicher Spektakel gemacht wie die
Sirenen während er dadurch geht sieht
man schon die ganzen Inszenierung und
Verlogenheit es geht hier um Leben und
Tod und ich möchte dass man an die
betroffenen Menschen denkt schwarze ganz
klare Aussage von ihnen zum Schluss
dieses Gespräch jetzt schauen wir auf
das Event morgen aus ihrer Sicht Event
mit Frau Wagenknecht und vermutlich sehr
vielen anderen auf der Straße mit wie
vielen rechnen sie morgen um 14 Uhr am
Brandenburger Tor es kann nicht schwer
sagen es kann nicht schwer sagen also
inzwischen hat die Polizei ihrer Präsenz
in den letzten zwei Tagen verdreifacht
bei der Stimmung und bei den Umfragen
eben und bei dieser knappen Mehrheit der
Bevölkerung die gegenwartung gekommen
die Frage ja viele die Frage ist bei so
einer Demo ab wann ist das eine
Enttäuschung ab wann ist das ein
Scheitern ab wann ist es ein Erfolg
haben sich darüber Gedanken gemacht nein
sowas mache ich niemals auch nicht wenn
ich schreibe ich tue das
was ich für richtig und nötig halte und
dann sehe ich ich gehe nicht von dem
Kalkül aus was wird dabei rauskommen
wenn Sie auch darüber werden sich
Gedanken gemacht haben vorne an der
Spitze dieser Menge stehen werden werden
sich ab und zu umdrehen und schauen wer
ist da noch dabei
ja kann ich Ihnen sagen die anderen
Redner wir sind fünf Redner und was
heißt Spitze bestehen auf einer Bühne
und wir sind fünf Redner und wer ich
will darauf hinaus interessiert es Sie
das war eine scharfe Kritik in den
vergangenen Tagen wer mit ihnen läuft
und was machen sie dafür eine
gewinnungsprüfung stellen sich ich
möchte sagen was denken sich die
Menschen dabei also wir leben in einer
Demokratie und das Recht zu produzieren
und zudem ist ein hohes Gut und es gibt
bisher keine gesinnungsprüfungen ja
hallo wir sind aber irgendwie komisch
machen und gucken sie kommen aber nicht
auf dem Platz dabei manche muss man
keine gesündungsprüfung machen
beispielsweise gesagt dass er morgen
nicht mitlaufen wird ich finde das
fantastisch
einer von 600.000 die das mal das
fantastisch also wir bleiben noch ein
paar andere übrig eh nein was wir nicht
erlauben werden wer ist sie das nicht
das politische Propaganda und natürlich
schon mal gar nicht rechtsextreme
Propaganda und auch nicht
rechtspopulistische das kann eigentlich
bei alle schwarzer und Sarah Wagen nicht
keine Überraschung sein weil unser
ganzes Leben und unser ganzes Engagement
ist recht ist eben nicht recht ist links
ist soziale Gerechtigkeit ist gegen
Gewalt ist gegen Krieg ja das ist
klassisch links das haben wir verstanden
das hat wahrscheinlich haben
wahrscheinlich auch Leute in der
Regierung vergessen was links oder
rechts ist
abschließend sie haben in diesem
Interview auch gesagt das ist auch
deswegen mutig weil es mich etwas kostet
weil es mich möglicherweise auch Freunde
kostet diese Diskussion das ich in
dieser Frage anderer Meinung bin hat es
sie tatsächlich Freundschaften gekostet
einen ein zwei aber ich muss sagen ich
steige da gar nicht ein also es können
absolut Freunde von mir andere Meinung
sein solange sie keine vernagelten
Ideologen und hat sich jemand von ihnen
abgewand der Ihnen wirklich wichtig war
bis jetzt nicht wirklich ja doch
vielleicht eine Person ja aber dafür hat
man wie General Vater auch morgen dabei
ist ja der General HD der militärische
Berater von der ex-kanzlerin Merkel der
hat gesagt ja ich habe ein paar Freunde
verloren aber ich habe viele neue
Freunde gewonnen und diese Antwort würde
ich auch geben wir haben heute dieses
Gespräch mit ihnen gesucht vor Ihrer
Veranstaltung am Samstag danke Ihnen für
das Gespräch vor schwarzer ich danke
Ihnen
und wir sind zurück in einer Woche hier
bei Bild mit den richtigen Fragen
[Musik]